العاجل الذي اوردناه قبل قليل حيث تحدثت
وسائل اعلام تابعه لانصار الله عن هجوم
امريكي بريطاني جديد استهدف منطقه الكثيب
في محافظه الحديده ومعنا من الحديده مراسل
الجزيره سمير النمري
سمير ما هي المعلومات عن هذا
الهجوم نعم عثمان بحسب مصادر في انصار
الله هنا في الحديده فان هناك غاره جويه
استهدفت منطقه الكثيب وهي منطقه سياحيه
نوعا ما وتشرف مباشره او تطل مباشره على
ميناء الحديده التجاري الذي يقع بالقرب
منها لا توجد حتى الان ايه اخبار تتحدث عن
ما هي الاضرار او ما هي المنطقه المستهدفه
ولكن في الغالب تقول قياده انصار الله ان
هذا ان هذه الضربات الجويه التي تشنها
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا غالبا ما
تستهدف معسكرات فارغه او مخلاه او قد تم
قصفها في وقت سابق وانه لا توجد هناك ايه
اضرار او تاثير على القوه العسكريه لانصار
الله وان هذه الغارات هي غارات عبثيه هذه
الغاره تاتي فقط بعد ساعات من استهداف عدد
من الغارات لمحافظه الحديده وكذلك صعده
حيث تقول قياده انصار الله ان عدوانا
امريكيا بريطانيا شن مساء امس
15 غاره على
محافظه الحديده وصعده منها ثمان غارات
منطقه راس راس عيس في شمال مدينه الحديده
وهذه المنطقه تضم ميناء نفطيا يسمى ميناء
راس عيسى وكذلك ايضا ثلاث غارات في مناطق
متفرقه من منطقه الزيديه وتقول قياده
انصار الله ان هذه المنطقه هي مناطق
زراعيه كذلك ايضا استهدفت محافظه صعده
الشرقيه مدينه صعده بنحو اربع غارات وتقول
كان محمد عبد السلام الناطق باسم انصار
الله قد قال يوم امس ان هذه القارات التي
تشنها الولايات المتحده لا تؤثر مطلقا على
القدرات اليمنيه العسكريه وانها فقط تف
اشغال الراي العام الامريكي والبريطاني
وانه لا توجد هناك اي تاثيرات شكرا شكرا
جزيلا لك كان ذلك مراسل الجزيره سمير نمري
من الحديده